nueve muertos y ocho heridos Este es el
balance de las víctimas de un ataque a
una unidad militar en el noroeste de
Colombia Se trata del atentado más
mortífero atribuido a la guerrilla del
eln desde el inicio de las negociaciones
de paz con el gobierno el presidente
Gustavo Petro condenó el asalto y llamó
a consultas a la delegación del gobierno
que participa en las conversaciones de
paz he convocado a consulta a la
delegación del gobierno en la mesa del
eln países garantes y acompañantes un
proceso de paz debe ser serio y
responsable con la sociedad colombiana
el ataque se produjo de madrugada en el
municipio de El Carmen en la región
fronteriza del catatumbo la mayoría de
los soldados fallecidos cumplían su
servicio militar obligatorio y tenían
unos 20 años el eln es el último gran
grupo guerrillero activo en Colombia
desde noviembre mantiene conversaciones
con el gobierno para poner fin a casi
seis décadas de un conflicto armado la
primera ronda de conversaciones terminó
en diciembre pero desde principios de
este año violencias y tensiones han
enfriado los diálogos nueve presuntos
miembros del eln murieron a finales de
enero en una ofensiva del ejército
colombiano el 10 de marzo al término de
la segunda Ronda de negociaciones en
México las partes se comprometieron a
iniciar negociaciones para un alto el
fuego Pero según los observadores las
dificultades del proceso se deben a que
el mando central del eln no siempre
tiene influencia sobre su base como lo
explicó a France 24 Néstor Rosalía es
una organización piramial jerárquica
como lo eran las FARC que tenía un Mando
Único y definido sino que aquí tienen
una autonomía en términos operacionales
cada una de estas unidades y por eso ni
siquiera muchas veces sabe lo que están
haciendo sus unidades en diferentes
zonas del país a principios de marzo una
tercera Ronda de conversaciones fue
anunciada esta vez en Cuba